ALREADY AHEAD OF THE PRESIDENT
HERE, ROSEMARY IN THEIR
THINKING.
>> NOW, NICK, WHILE I HAVE YOU
HEAR, I WANT TO READ OUT.
WE HAVE THE FORMAL JOINT
STATEMENT RIGHT NOW THAT JUST
POSTED BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
REPUBLIC AND PRIME MINISTER OF
FINLAND AND FINLAND'S NATO
MEMBERSHIP.
I WILL READ A PART OF IT IF NOT
ALL, IT READS THUS, DURING THIS
SPRING, AN IMPORTANT DISCUSSION
ON FINLAND'S POSSIBLE NATO
MEMBERSHIP HAS TAKEN PLACE AND
TIME HAS BEEN NEEDED TO LET
PARLIAMENT AND THE WHOLE SOCIETY
ESTABLISH THEIR STAND ON THE
MATTER.
WE HAVE WANTED TO GIVE THE
DISCUSSION THE SPACE IT
REQUIRED.
IT GOES ON AND SAYS, NOW THAT
THE MOMENT OF DECISION MAKING IS
NEAR, WE STATE OUR EQUAL VIEWS,
ALSO FOR INFORMATION TO THE
PARLIAMENTARY GROUPS AND
PARTIES, NATO MEMBERSHIP WOULD
STRENGTHEN FINLAND'S SECURITY.
AS A MEMBER OF NATO, IT WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE DEFENSE ALLIANCE
AND MUST APPLY FOR MEMBERSHIP
WITHOUT DELAY.
WE HOPE THE NATIONAL STEPS STILL
NEEDED TO MAKE THIS DECISION
WILL BE TAKEN RAPIDLY WITHIN THE
NEXT FEW DAYS.
NOW, SO, THAT'S, THAT'S THE GIST
OF IT, IT'S QUITE EXTRAORDINARY,
THE SPEED AT WHICH THIS HAS
MOVED AS WE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING.
AND OF COURSE, WHAT THIS WILL
MEAN FOR RUSSIA, IS IT PUTS NATO
RIGHT AT ITS DOORSTOP.
REALLY, THIS, THIS HAS BEEN THE
PROBLEM AND THE TRIGGER FOR
RUSSIA INVADING UKRAINE AND NOW,
THE PROBLEM WILL BE HOW RUSSIA
WILL RESPOND TO THIS?
>> YES, AND WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IN THE LAST FEW DAYS
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE HEARD
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYING THAT
HE GETS A SENSE THAT PRESIDENT
PUTIN IS BOXED IN BY HIS ACTIONS
IN UKRAINE BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
SUCCESSFUL, HE DOES NOT SEE AN
OFF RAMP, FINLAND AND SWEDEN
JOINING NATO.
LET'S JUST ANALYZE ONE SECOND
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD THERE FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND PRIME
MINISTER.
IT'S THEM SAYING THIS IS THE
RIGHT MOVE.
WE KNOW THAT ABOUT 3/4 OF THE
POPULATION HERE AGREE WITH THAT,
AND I SPOKE TO SOMEBODY IN THE
PRIME MINISTER AND NP WITHIN THE
PRIME MINISTER'S PARTY YESTERDAY
AND HE SAID WHEN HE THOUGHT IT
COMES TO A VOTE IN PARLIAMENT OF
200 MEMBERS, 180 WOULD AT LEAST
VOTE IN FAVOR OF JOINING THE
NATO MEMBERSHIP.
THIS WAS A SMALL STEP TO GO.
BUT IT WAS A BIG AND SIGNIFICANT
ANNOUNCEMENT GIVEN EVERYTHING
THAT WE KNOW.
WE KNOW THE PRIME MINISTER'S
PARTY ON SATURDAY IS GOING TO
MAKE A DECISION AND IT'S CLEARLY
GOING TO SUPPORT NATO MEMBERSHIP
AND ON SUNDAY WE ARE EXPECTING
THE FIVE-PARTY COALITION THAT
RUNS THE COUNTRY TO MAKE THEIR
DECISION ABOUT NATO MEMBERSHIP
AND AGAIN, EXPECTED TO BE ON THE
SAME FOREIGN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
AND EXPECTED TO PRESENT THE
PARLIAMENT NEXT WEEK AND YES,
THIS WILL, THIS WILL REALIZE
PRESIDENT PUTIN'S FEARS IN HIS
MIND, IT'S NOT AN ACTION AGAINST
RUSSIA.
THE FINNISH PRESIDENT WAS KEEN
TO STATE THAT, IT'S AN ACTION
AGAINST FINLAND SECURITY, IT'S
NOT AN ACTION AGAINST ANYONE, HE
SAID LAST NIGHT AND THAT MEANS
RUSSIA.
BUT FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN, HE WILL
SEE THE REVERSE AFFECT OF THE
REASON WHY HE WENT TO WAR IN
UKRAINE.
NATO NOW DOUBLES THE LENGTH OR
IS LIKELY TO NOW DOUBLE THE
LENGTH OF THE BORDER WITH
RUSSIA.
AND FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN, TRYING
TO FIND AN EXIT STRATEGY THAT HE
CAN SELL TO RUSSIANS FOR HIS AS
HE CALLS IT A SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION AND WAR IN UKRAINE,
THE FAILURE TO KEEP NATO AT BAY
IN HIS TERMS AND IN FACT, THE
INCREASE OF NATO'S PRESENCE IN
HIS TERMS ON RUSSIA'S BORDER
WILL BE AN EVEN HARDER SELL.
HOW RUSSIA REACTS TO THIS IS
WHAT CONCERNS FINLAND AT THE
MOMENT.
AND THIS IS WHAT WE ARE HEAR